vamos ahora al problema 129 en el
problema 129 nos dicen que en es un
entero positivo n es entero entero
positivo
y lo que queremos determinar es si ve -
a es al menos el doble de 3 a la n 2 a
la n nos preguntan si ve - a es al menos
es mayor o igual que el doble de 3 a la
n menos 2 a la n vamos a ver qué dicen
los incisos de información en el inciso
número 1 nos dicen que a que es igual a
2 a la n 1
y que ve es igual a 3 a la n 1 de esta
forma ver si esta desigualdad se cumple
es lo mismo a ver si se cumple cuando
sustituimos estas variables o sea lo que
tenemos que checar es 3 a la n-1 menos 2
a la n 1 es mayor o igual que dos por
tres a la n 2 a la n bueno multiplicando
por dos del lado derecho es decir
haciendo esta multiplicación nos
quedaría que 3 a la n-1 menos 2 a la n 1
es mayor o igual que dos por tres a la n
menos dos a la n 12 por 2 a la n es 2 a
la n 12 a la n 1 bueno entonces está
esta desigualdad es equivalente a esta
que es equivalente a esta ahora podemos
sumar 2 a la n 1 de ambos lados para que
aquí se cancele y aquí también de modo
que no nos bastaría verificar que 3 a la
n 1 le gané a 2 por 3 a la n y ahora lo
que podemos hacer es dividir entre 3 a
la n iv observa que podemos hacerlo
porque 3 a la n no es negar
3 a la n siempre es positivo aunque n no
fuera un entero positivo por ejemplo si
n fuera menos 13 a la enee seguiría
siendo positivo sería un tercio pero
bueno aquí incluso nos dicen que es
entero positivo entonces bueno de todas
formas dividiendo entre 3 a la n no se
cambia el signo de la desigualdad así
que lo hacemos entre 3 a la n entre 3 a
la n de este lado se cancelan los 3 a la
n y aquí nos queda 3 a la n 1 entre 3 a
la n que usando leyes de los exponentes
sería 3 a la n 1 n es decir 3 de modo
que esta desigualdad es equivalente a
que 3 sea mayor o igual que 2 lo cual es
cierto
vale entonces está de acá es cierta y
por lo tanto con el inciso 1 sí podemos
responder la pregunta vamos a ver ahora
qué dice el inciso 2 en el inciso 2
nos dicen que n es igual a 3 n es igual
a 3 si ponemos en e igual a 3 aquí lo
que lo que queremos ver es si ve - a es
mayor o igual
que dos veces dos veces tres al cubo
menos dos al jugo sale es decir queremos
ver si me ve menos a es mayor o igual
que 2 por 27 menos 8 y esto de aquí es
igual a 2 por 19 que es 38 sale pero en
realidad no tenemos nada de información
debe menos así únicamente tenemos este
inciso verdad entonces con esto no vamos
a poder responder esta pregunta en
realidad haber hecho estas cuentas
incluso fue un poquito una pérdida de
tiempo porque pues desde el principio se
ve que aquí esto no tiene nada que ver
ni con nada ni con ve y entonces va a
estar en chino poder responder esta
pregunta vale entonces la respuesta
sería que únicamente el inciso a nos
permite responder esta pregunta
esta es la respuesta vale bueno ahora
vamos al problema 130 el problema 130
dice lo siguiente dice la inflación para
el año 1989 con respecto al año 1970 fue
3.56 lo cual quiere decir que en
promedio por cada peso gastado en 1970
en ciertos bienes se tuvieron que gastar
3.56 pesos por esos mismos bienes en
1989 a ver dejarlo a punto por aquí
entonces en 1970 si si pagábamos un peso
pues después en 1989 lo que pagamos es
3.56 entonces 3.56 es la la inflación ok
y luego dice si el precio de una
batidora aumentó exactamente de acuerdo
a la inflación cuál era su precio en
1970 entonces tenemos una batidora y
queremos saber su precio en 1970
ok déjame bajar un poco para hacer un
poco de espacio y vamos a ver qué nos
dicen los incisos de información en el
inciso 1 nos dice que el precio de la
batidora fue 102.4 pesos más en 1989 que
en 1970 ok entonces el precio de la
batidora en 1989 fue 102.4 pesos mas
102.4 pesos más en 1989 que en 1970 los
200 2.4 más de 70 vamos a ver si con
esto podemos podemos determinar el valor
de bs 70
bueno pues tenemos esta ecuación de aquí
y además tenemos esta información de la
inflación verdad o sea tenemos que que
si el precio de 1970 es de 70 de 70
entonces el precio de 1989 que es de 89
también lo podemos poner como 3.56 x vez
70 por 70 entonces de aquí ya se ve que
vamos a poder resolver el problema
verdad para encontrar de 70 simplemente
sustituimos este valor acá y nos queda
3.56 b 70 es igual a 102.4 más b 70 y
esto de aquí ya es una ecuación lineal
en una variable que se puede resolver
vale entonces este inciso si funciona
para responder la pregunta vamos a ver
qué dice el inciso número dos en el
inciso número dos nos dicen que el
precio de la batidora en 1989 o sea de
89 fue igual a 140 y 2.4 140 y 2.4 y por
supuesto que de aquí también vamos a
poder encontrar de 70 verdad simplemente
volvemos a usar esta igualdad tenemos
entonces que 3.56 de 70 es igual a 140 y
2.4 y aquí podemos dividir entre ambos
por 3.56 nos quedaría be 70 igual a 142
punto 4 dividir a ambos lados entre 3.56
vale bueno entonces cualquiera de los
dos sirve para responder la pregunta así
que la respuesta sería de muy bien vamos
ahora al 131 problemas 131
131 aquí nos preguntan si 5 alak a la
pregunta 5 a la k es menor que 1000
menor que mí
muy bien en el inciso 1 lo que nos dicen
es que 5 a la cama 15 a la k más uno es
mayor que 3000 mayor que 3000 y esto en
realidad nada más nos va a dar una cota
inferior verdad esto no nos va a servir
para determinar si 5 a la k es menor que
1000 es más déjame ser un poco más
explícito en eso observa 5 a la cama su
no es lo mismo que 5 por 5 a la acá al
acá sale entonces esta información de
aquí arriba es lo mismo decir que 5 por
5 a la k le gana 3 mil y ahora podemos
dividir entre ambos lados y podemos
dividir a ambos lados entre 5 nos
quedarían cinco a la k mayor que 600
pudimos hacer eso porque 5 es positivo
verdad bueno entonces tenemos 5 alaca
mayor que 600 pero esto únicamente nos
da una cota por abajo a partir de esto
no podemos determinar si 5 a la k es
digamos 625 o si 5 a la k es la
siguiente potencia que es como tres mil
125 o algo así y en un caso si quedaría
menor que 1000 y en otro caso no
nada más con la información del inciso 1
no podemos responder esta pregunta le
voy a poner una tache
ahora vamos al inciso 2 en el inciso 2
lo que nos dicen es que 5 a la cama 15
al acá a la cárcel dice más uno dice
menos 1 perdón 5 al acá menos uno es
igual a 5 al aca 5 al aca menos 500
menos 500 esta de aquí se ve como una
información más útil verdad porque a ver
si es una igualdad vamos a ver si
podemos trabajar para determinar si 5 a
la k es menor que 1000
entonces lo que voy a hacer es pasar
este 5 alak a la izquierda es decir
restó 5 a la k de ambos lados me queda 5
a la k menos uno menos 5 a la cam es
igual a menos 500 menos 500 y ahora lo
que voy a hacer es factorizar un 5 al
acá de aquí me quedaría 5 al a cada x 5
a la menos uno sale 5 al acá por 5 al
menos 15 alaca menos uno
- 1 - 1 esto de aquí es igual a menos
500 menos 500 y voy a simplificar esto
vaya voy a trabajar con esto 5 a la
menos uno es un quinto entonces sería 5
al acá por un quinto
- 1 es igual a menos 500 vale y ahora
esta es equivalente a 5 a la cam 5 alak
a un quinto menos 1 es menos cuatro
quintos menos cuatro quintos
igual a menos 500
- 500 vale lo que voy a hacer es cambiar
el signo de ambos lados y ahora este 4
lo voy a pasar dividiendo multiplicó por
4 de ambos lados dividido entre 4 de
ambos lados más bien me queda 5 al ak
por un quinto es igual a 500 entre 2 es
es 250 y entre 12 125 es igual a 125 y
finalmente este 5 lo paso multiplicando
5 alacant es igual a 625 estuvieron un
poco largas estas cuentas pero con esto
determinamos que el valor de 5 a la k es
625 el cual definitivamente es menor que
entonces la información del inciso b si
nos permite determinar la respuesta de
esta pregunta la información del inciso
2 más bien y entonces la respuesta sería
b vale el inciso 2 sirve para responder
la pregunta pero el inciso 1 es inútil
ya se me acabó el tiempo para este vídeo
nos vemos en el siguiente para continuar
con estas preguntas